all right so welcome joy hey we also got
the worth of getting in the back what up
and you know we chose you Joyce or the
co-host on an episode because of your
love for music I did see a performance
of yours back it up Santa oh yes I
backed it up back to that fashion for
Santa today I wasn't lifestyle will give
you training three headphones at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
as price worth it worth it okay Joyce so
Tess headphones you and me are gonna
pick our favorite song right now or
something has meaning to us over and
we're gonna be testing that song at
three different headphones already yeah
you make decisions very quickly I'm a
Gemini have to hit on her way to a
relatively low price pretty new audio
company I want good sounds I want
portability I want affordability
I want that bass to bump like Nicki
Minaj what about you
I just want good sound quality you ready
yeah
headphones headphones which headphones
alright
my name is James Bertuzzi I'm the
founder of status audio the vision for
the company was always headphones
personal audio products the most
challenging part about building
headphones is that you're combining
technology with this whole wearable
component it's got to fit and it has to
look good because if those things aren't
working then it doesn't matter how great
the tech is it's like oh what the I am 2
X game just walk me through the
specifications it's a cable to your
buddy so the way we envisioned this
product was as sort of an everyday
product for an audiophile who owns a lot
of other products that aren't practical
to use sort of day-to-day we go to an
industrial designer and we start you
know sketching out ideas and 3d printing
is where we get the chance to just see
the product in space really the most
compelling features the fact that it's
dual driver one handles the low end
that's the dynamic driver and the other
the balanced armature driver handles the
the mids and the highs they're actually
technology that's repurposed from
hearing aids and they're used for
musicians on stage they use ba drivers
you know we're a digital first brand
we're finding customers to be
unbelievably resourceful and
sophisticated they seek out reviews from
different places editorial YouTube
fortunately we've come out on on the
right side of that and people are really
embracing what we're doing we have the
IEM 2x giving our first impressions well
I love the thick wiring yeah it is
fabric look at that that's cool yeah I
feel like this is something I could put
in the bottom of my purse looks like she
doesn't get tangled that much like she
knows who she is she pays her rent pays
her rent on time look at that on here's
the thing I hate white headphones I hate
white headphones because I am a black
woman and I were makeup by the end of a
month it's gonna be fully brown because
you know like I wear them on the go when
I have my makeup on so my makeup gets on
it I have similar problems because I'm
just a dirty person putting them right
away they are very comfortable yes so
we're gonna play our songs my relation
to pop culture is very interesting I
kind of had our Thomas into music and I
realized growing up it's because I
couldn't relate to the people who were
making that content
so what was game-changing for me was
actually a music group card for this
movement
you know them yeah okay it's called
bamboo alright nice listen yeah this is
the first headphone where I feel like
it's up in my face yes like it's quite
they're literally over you in here I
feel like the world is drowned out like
I'm underwater yeah all I can hear is
this the dual driver yeah yeah you get a
good sense of the different tones so
what is your song I'd rather go blind by
Etta James you know it's a song about
heartbreak and I love sad songs I'm
three two
[Music]
man do you think is amazing can you say
that you think is beautiful Wow
I see what you mean you like that sad
stuff work on the streets iron the
sheets the fence audio anything I think
help in fact many people point to the
Walkman introduced in 1979 as the
beginning of the widespread use of
headphones I still can't believe people
are out here with our headphones living
their best rights like before writing
something like what were they doing
it's my parents are like 14 at the time
I'll call your mom
higher mom on her phone her mom is my
lifeline that's C my life watch thank
you hi mama I have a question for you
I'm shooting for worth it so do you
remember your life before headphones so
do you remember your life before
headphones oh thanks for letting me know
what's out of her first walk what she
remembers yes we're gonna get out of the
cold yes and we'll go on to her vine to
a place called Ellis TN I'm Joe Hough
I'm Bridget Hilton and we're here at
listen sound Co we really wanted to
start something with a purpose and we
noticed that there was nothing going on
in audio space or the music space that
really gave back at the same time we
actually saw this video of a woman
hearing for the first time that was the
same age as me so we started a headphone
company that gave that for every product
that we sell we fund our charity partner
Starkey Hearing Foundation and they help
provide hearing aids to people all
around the world that have hearing
disabilities since we've launched about
seven years ago we've been able to help
over 30,000 people get hearing aids
we're both musicians when my sense
that's what we were looking around at
like guitars and pianos and our
instruments and everything's made of
wood so we thought wire
phones made out of wood so we made some
and not only do they look cool and
unique the sound quality actually sounds
great it's game what makes a good pair
of headphones it turns out when you have
a lower quality audio product people
have a tendency to try to turn it up by
having a product that people can enjoy
music to and not actually damage their
hearing because of our mission to help
give hearing we have an in-house
proprietary driver that we've developed
with our factory part of our work life
is traveling around the world doing
these hearing missions so we wear our
headphones for 10 hours at a time all
the time so comfort was really key so
we're trying to make a really high
quality product that looks good does
good sounds good and also is like a
great price attainable price so what is
that price Wireless Troubadour is 170
$9.99 okay you ready to pop this open
yes I love a good unboxing me too pow oh
yeah oh yeah that vegan leather spot the
headphones are beautiful and you're
beautiful but you and the headphones is
just I don't want I am NOT cool with the
kids but I'm gonna say it's straight
fire and I say that any shaking your
head all these like wonderful
marshmallows for my ear good okay
let's connect these yeah so let's both
listen to mine first
[Music]
that's really impressive and the fact
that I can go over my big head
especially what I'm that's really
important all right
Joyce you're up I'm gonna hit you with
that classic that did sound
if somebody thoughts I want to be alone
in my house with my 7-eleven wine that
listening that song crying while texting
my ex telling him he never deserved a
woman like me I thought the balance of
the music was really good
and when you buy these you are helping
somebody else out so we drive and beep
beep beep beep beep hey fun fact
headphones on its own [ __ ] this is a head
from the fact but this fact will not lie
so the fact is the headphones are the
ninth most lost item in ubers time I
left my whole exome over oh god oh we're
going to a place called great oh ok they
make really really high quality
headphones they have an amazing sound
and I can't wait to check it out we're
in Brooklyn New York at Gradle labs
I'm Jonathan great oh and I'm John great
oh and today we'll be looking at our
flagship headphone PS mm II what are the
components of the headphone that are
going to achieve that sound that you are
trying to get to the greater sound is a
very lush rich warm mid-range when we
design we don't use meters and graphs we
don't want a machine telling us what
we're hearing ok so we listen and I
often like to say that wick we're kind
of like chefs chef has to taste their
food to know what's good it's how all
the ingredients work with each other on
the outside it's a smoked chrome housing
we built a maple chamber inside so it's
a wooden chamber inside of the metal
it's our only pair of where maple and
metal meet their little effects but when
you put the whole thing together we feel
to get the best sound out of something
you really have to isolate the driver or
the speaker so it can just work
effortlessly it's a special driver we
use it in this headphone only what shall
we pay attention to when will this move
my father was the artist he said well
you look at a picture walk up to the
picture look at the brushstrokes see how
the picture was constructed you know
they'll be heavy brushstrokes lighter
ones the mixture of the colors and
everything then step back
and enjoy the picture and it's kind of
the same thing with the music the PS
2000 is for really listening and really
like surgically getting into the song
and being able to enjoy it not just as a
song but being able to see what makes
that song so great we're here now in the
listening room this is the most
expensive thing I've ever put on my head
it just seemed so classic it's a good
wait so like if I want to ignore like
strangers on the street I know that I
won't hear a single word that's coming
out of there well you you just develop
that entire opinion in like half of a
second honestly it's what I do with most
people so to start we're gonna listen to
John's favorite reference tracks Eric
Clapton it's the Unplugged album and we
want to listen to the applause the
clapping of the hands whoa oh wow oh wow
whoa okay
first impression go I'm very dramatic I
literally felt like I was hearing for
the first time I was just there Duke
Ellington the Jays party is gonna be a
xylophone playing you'll hear the decay
as a team okay this is crazy I feel like
there are a thousand instruments in my
ear right now this is for K for years it
really is like you're there but it's not
like you're siloed there it's like
you're there and space goes into
eternity yes
Wow sound like where I and Ella
Fitzgerald and they see you listening to
the woman's voice and before I mentioned
about the mid range the mid range is
where the voice is all I feel like her
vibrato is just this is just going
through my body right now now we're
gonna close with of course the one
you've been listening to bamboo
[Music]
it's like Pixar movies you know how
advanced I've gotten at showing each
blade of grass back in the day you would
see like four pixels okay so we're gonna
play Etta cuz I love her it was just
like that overwhelming feeling of
wanting someone it hit me like I heard
it for the first time you know
[Laughter]
headphones wrap out take one mark we're
here at the BuzzFeed recording studio we
lay down some tracks yes
little railroad yes but for you what was
the most worth it headphone at its given
price point the most life it had fun was
great oh oh so what about you thank you
for asking
status audio really high sound quality
more than you would expect at that price
yeah but can I heard great oh I was like
wow however I really had to stay and
listen was my were that winner Wow I
know they are literally giving people
hearing okay Andrew who was the most
worth it for you Annie is it work that
we whip around the world cuz you know
we've got our ski boots with you and
dance and everywhere that sound in the
world
ah see you next week on with lifestyle
we're doing engagement rings he married
me
[Music]
[Music]